stop me have you ever heard this one
before my hero academia is a good show
we only want to keep shutting up about
it
it's no secret by now that my hero
academia is a popular show that is loved
by a few people having just wrapped up
one of the biggest and most impactful
fights the series has given thus far
whenever the few complaints I
occasionally see that I actually kind of
agree we've given how much I like
talking about and analyzing anime fights
is that when comparing this shows fights
to the hype battle scene is similar
shows my ear or academia fights can
actually seem a bit dull well well well
before you unsubscribe and smash that
dislike button let me have a chance to
explain myself what I mean by dull is
just how one-dimensional and simple the
action technically is if you think about
some of the best aspects of amazing
fights and other shows and you think of
the choreography of Naruto fights the
complexity of men battle scene in Hunter
hunter the pure spectacle of one punch
man bouts the over-the-top
ridiculousness of Stan fights and jojos
they all have their unique selling
points on how to make a fight scene
dynamic and good have I broken down
different ways to make a fight team
dynamic I don't have a problem I just
really like anime fights okay in
contrast with Hiro RK let's forget about
that final beautifully animated moment
for a second okay if you actually break
down a lot of the action the fights and
Karaka are far more simplistic and
bog-standard
you don't think of beautiful
choreography of regional action
directional game change in tactics the
philosophy is go beyond plus ultra a
mantra to go past your limits to emerge
victorious which is dangerously close to
the cheap-ass pause we would usually
criticizing others shown in titles which
is why most flights should just end with
a simple strategy finding ways to make
your quark power more powerful or often
boiling things down into a single clash
one beautifully animated clash
that's but one clash nonetheless that
trumps any moment of the fight itself
meaning that for the most part the
action and the fight is just
well this isn't a negative video I swear
you see despite everything I just said I
love these fights I love every fight
well most of them and they will
undoubtedly go down as some of the
greatest fights in anime history and for
a good [ __ ] reason too because how
the hell can you deny the pure
unfiltered hype that is moments like
these so what am I trying to say
well it was after reflecting on the
simplicity of the big fights I kept
seeing and looking back at the series as
a whole I believe we've been thinking
about my hero academia the wrong way
with three seasons underway the Carson
world thoroughly established and the
identity of what the show actually is
about laid out I would like to propose
an idea for you my hero academia is not
first and foremost as shown in battle
series
yeah I just said that instead my here
accademia simple fights are only there
to showcase the writing and world
building because these fights are not
about the fights okay before you
brutalize me with your merciless words
let me try to illustrate my points by
taking one of the biggest fights of last
year deku versus Todoroki now as hype as
this fight may have made you feel you
can't deny that if we actually break
down the action it all boils down to us
literally cheering at a boy figuring out
the best way to break his fingers at
some ice oh my God he's breaking his
fingers can this get any more hype oh my
god it's breaking it's broken fingers
fingers but you know he's learned full
cowling now so he probably won't see
this anymore but as we all know this is
not what made the fight brilliant it was
Totoro keys painful backstory
it was dec whose heroics and convinced
him to accept himself through his words
and finger breaking skills and it was
Todoroki finally coming to accept it all
we capsulated into this final
beautifully animated moment this is a
pattern you will see in every fight that
has any significant screen time in it
deku breaking more fingers just to
literally push a guy out of the ring
Todoroki trying to give back a go some
of this chill because he obviously
hasn't almighty figuring out that all he
needs to do to defeat the guy who was
genetically designed to absorb his
punches is to punch more but let's not
forget the granddaddy you all for one a
villain who can take any quirk he likes
basically given free rein to creatively
use different quirks in any combination
he can imagine allowing him to flexibly
approach a fight using countless
different methods and what does he do he
activates his ultimate quirk combination
wankers cramp so he can shoot wind a bit
more power for the out of his hands I
mean I love my Shonen anime so I've seen
some pretty inventive use of powers but
come on man with the possibility they
had there is more creative power using
black Naruto
I'm just being pedantic here though
because I love each and every fighter
just listed and took the piss out of its
just for a different reason
my hero academia epitomizes how a fight
is not always about the action often
times it bores it down to as simple as
it can be so it doesn't detract from
themes that have been laid out in the
conflict in the previous video of mine
I've said the line every fight tells a
story well in here akka the fight is the
story what I've come to realize is that
the show has done the majority of its
storytelling through its fights every
single one of them has a purpose yes
even this one which shone a light on the
motivations of this this scrotum head
thirsty ass [ __ ] boy who thought it
would be a cool idea to have a hero
costume that includes wearing diapers
because if they don't have a purpose
they are glossed over and not given any
screen time in fact the tournament arc
an arc normally use give an excuse for
fast-paced consecutive action was turned
entirely into a character-building arc
turn Iraqis hatred and relationship with
his father Barca goes violent tendencies
being broadcasted Erica's drive to catch
her with deku class B's inferiority
complex with Class A these are all
things set up in the tournament that
either affects how characters currently
act or have directly affected future
events if you actually think about it in
the grand scheme of things for a show
passing fifty episodes now not too much
has happened
we've had you a exams then the league of
villains attack their nurse structured
series of individual flight sock then
the league of villains attack and then
we have you a exams and then the league
of villains attack with this tie ball
might loses its powers it's taken us 49
episodes for something of heavy
consequence it happened in the wider
plot but it doesn't feel like any of
that times been wasted because most of
everything has happened so far has been
character development and world building
because there have been multiple times
my perception of the show has changed
thanks to its fights initially I thought
this show is about this simplistic view
of heroes and villains here look I even
say it here casing the simple tropes
have shown in battle series were
polishing everything down to a tee the
fact that we literally had to hear our
alliance and a league of villains laid
out couldn't have been any more black or
white at the time I didn't understand
why villains would even want to call
themselves villains in this world but I
just went along with it because hey not
everything needs to be explored if
you're playing to establish Shonen
tropes so well but as the series went on
that simplicity was challenged the stain
fight aside from actually being the most
complex fight the show has been able to
muster so far was vastly importer
for the world-building as it is this
fight that shutters are simplistic view
of hair society as it exists in this
universe it introduced this gray area
and a level of depth we hadn't seen
within the villains of this world it
forces us to question what the
difference is between a hero and a
villain whether villains can act just
and heroes act unjust and this would go
on to affect the villains that are later
introduced and even develop our main
villain who initially looked very
OneNote this fight in the aftermath is
so goddamn important to the world
building an overall narrative but if you
continue looking you will realize that
every fight we've been presented with
has been done in service of developing
the cast or the world we cheer for all
might because he's throwing his punches
to firmly uphold his image as the symbol
of peace we feel bucko his frustration
when Todoroki can't bring himself to
muster his full strength we became a kid
again when Deku threw his first punch to
use the powers he never had growing up
every action has been given meaning
behind it which is why most fly's boil
down to that single superbly animated
clash because the weight of that clash
is ridiculously heavy and it doesn't
necessarily need to be a punch or a
fight it can be pretty much any moment
of character action that's been given
weight and meaning to
[Music]
these are not fights these are climaxes
to narrative or character arcs which
happy to be concluded with a punch which
is one the series doesn't need overly
complex or unique action in fact they
could probably replace it with anime
thumb-wrestling and I would still have
the same impact the fight itself doesn't
matter it's how it serves its purpose in
the grander scheme of things and this is
why it certainly doesn't feel like
they're shown in battle series we are
used to seeing we are used to ground
adventures with a lot of detours and a
lot a lot of escalation we can go off on
an adventure to find your dad and find
yourself in the middle of a black market
underground war martial arts tournaments
that turn into intergalactic martial
arts tournaments or the endless things
explored in one piece to have nothing to
do with piracy and those aren't
criticisms but in my ear academia every
argh every character every clash has
revolved around the themes of heroism I
can't think of any other shown in battle
series where every event and character
happens in service to explore its one
core theme and one way the progression
feels completely natural that is
building towards a pre-planned plot
structure we are towards right at the
beginning that this is the story of how
Dec who becomes the greatest hero then
if that is indeed true everything that
happened has been a perfect act one set
up the world has been established
characters are all introduced and the
stage has been set for the new
generation of heroes this is what I mean
when I say is not first and foremost as
shown in battle series it's a character
drama it's a well written superhero
character drama one with an established
world of society with a rich cast of
characters with their own ideologies
those who oppose the society that's been
crafted and those who fight to protect
it it's an epoch that just happens to
tell a lot of its story through action
scenes and I'm not saying other shown in
battle series don't use their fights for
world building and character development
but what I've come to realize is that
this is what hero ARCA almost
exclusively does and I think this is why
the show's managed to grow so much in
popularity and capturing an audience
even outside of the usual shown in trash
[ __ ] boys like me it consistently is
able to tell very human stories and is
exploring some interesting ideas behind
the facade of shiny bombastic shown in
action and this is where we can go back
to this
have you returned my students all for
one because this fight may have
technically had very simple action man
successfully punches this man who was
trying to blow away this man but it
doesn't really matter because it was
never about the action this was about
all might it was him giving one last
hurrah emerging victorious to keep hope
and Trust alive for Heroes and inspiring
the next generation it was about
upholding his image as the symbol of
peace and making sure his ideals were
kept we were this audience watching and
cheering the end of this first act
watching his ideology being passed on to
the next generation watching the end of
an era dominated by a figure of legend
boiling it down to one scene I'm sure
will go down in history is one of the
most impactful moments for this modern
anime generation
and that's why my hero academia succeeds
with these dull fights because there's
so much packed in so little there's so
much weight so much meaning there's
[ __ ] your knees breaking his broken
arm
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to
Nicolas Tatum can you must live basil
Patrick Madison Vincent Mooney now Ken
and everyone else on patreon for helping
to support me for this month and making
this video possible it's only a week to
lay eggs and also holy [ __ ] I have so
much work to do before I fly off but if
you're going up we'll be posting my
schedule soon and if you're in LA that's
let's [ __ ] do it it's gonna be high
well I apologize I design a lot of
coffee and I'm filming this on caffeine
I probably wasn't the best idea anyway
that's it for today I will see you there
in a week and if you're not gonna be in
LA then I will see you on my next video
whatever that is till next time